frédéric vandenbergh bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors jaillir bolton a sonné zitka on
l'a vu à s'afficher dans des bains de
foule il n'applique pas les gestes
barrière est ce que sa position a évolué
ces derniers jours sur sa vision des
choses vis-à-vis du corps d'un virus non
c'est à dire que depuis quelques
semaines maintenant
il nie tout simplement éliminé milices
et les risques donc nous n'avons vu une
première fois le 15 mars lorsqu'il avait
ya appelé à une manifestation contre son
propre gouvernement
disons qu'il voulait mettre sous
pression le congrès et en même temps
aussi le supl sur le disons la cour la
cour suprême et là il est sorti au même
moment il a pris un premier bain de
foule et depuis lors il le fait en
général le dimanche mais le les derniers
jours il est parti plus souvent donc on
l'a vu hier où il est certes sorti
encore une fois il est parti ya disons
dans une dans une pâtisserie où il a
acheté woods berlin et en sortant
évidemment voir il salue les personnes à
être lui donne la main et ce qu'on voit
en quelque sorte c'est justement un
président qui fait en quelque sorte
opposition voire contre son propre
gouvernement contre son le ministre de
la santé qui lui suit les consignes de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
alors justement comment comprendre cette
posture du président brésilien est ce
que c'est un calcul politique
ou alors ce sont véritablement de
profonde conviction qu'il ya un peu il
ya un peu de 2 d2 il ya évidemment un
calcul politique parce qu'il sait bien
qu'il ya disons les effets il ya
économiques seront vraiment moins
dramatique et dont encore en en prenant
en quelque sorte le relâchement du
confinement
il essaye de mettre dix ont la
responsabilité sur les gouverneurs donné
tu as donc comme au brésil il ya la fois
l'état fédéral et puis à les états donc
bien que de ça mais en plus je crois que
tout ce qu'il s'agit tout simplement
voix
disons d'une personne à genève qui
persiste et signe
ce n'est pas la première fois vous vous
rappelez sans doute nous avons vu un
même comportement délinquant d'aller
passer lors de la 10 ont de la
désastreuse de la forêt de l'amazonie
c'est à dire qu'ils négligent ou plutôt
il nie tout simplement les évidences
scientifiques les évidents statistiques
ayant il persiste et signe alors vous
parler de la question et co2 mais
justement au brésil 38 millions de
personnes travaillent dans le secteur
informel avec le confinement cette
population va être en première ligne est
ce qu'il y aura des aides de l'état
prévu pour ces travailleurs qui est des
aides de l'état qui sont prévues meyer
le gouvernement va par son art au suit
une ligne d'un néo libéralisme radical
au départ là encore ce qu'on a vu
c'était tout simplement que le
gouvernement ne voulait pas changer sa
politique
au départ il avait promis 200 rayon war
par mois pour les informels puis disons
par une sorte de surenchère on est
arrivés ya six ans ou leurs ayants droit
par mois ci qui évidemment voix est très
peu s'en versent enverrait à et ce sens
verrait au gua par mois disons que le
gouvernement prend plutôt soins disons 2
comment dire des employeurs que des gens
courrier est évidemment le rendent
ramsay les informels c'est ce qui se
trouve dans les marges de la société
alors il ya aussi la question des
favelas sein qui suscite des
interrogations jeudi dernier les
autorités ont enregistré les six
premiers décès dans ces quartiers
pauvres
est ce qu'on peut craindre une hécatombe
justement dans ces quartiers est ce que
l'état met en place des mesures pour les
éviter
il ya un décalage entre les numéro un
officiel
et puis évidemment la réalité puisque
nous n'avons pas de tests ayant ce qu'on
voit maintenant en tout cas dès l'été
dernier jo c'est effectivement un
déplacement un déplacement des quartiers
plutôt huppés et on voit que le virus
est en train d'arriver dans les favelas
et dans les favelas évidemment la
situation est complètement différente
comment laver ses mains quand on n'a pas
l'eau courante comme emprunt pratiqué à
la distance sociale
quand on a une famille aux deux familles
qui habitent dans une seule pièce donc
au là effectivement on s'attend mois on
s'attend à l'hécatombe
merci beaucoup frédéric van den berghe
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
sociologie à l'université fédérale de
rio dé janeiro